I'm going to cheat a little bit i gave
you two questions we should be asking
ourselves first and most important
question how are we to live as opposed
to we tend to ask how we to to force
other people to live so I think the
first thing always need to ask ourselves
is how should we live how do want to
inspire our neighbors if we care about
global warming let's not put in their
first question therefore should we
regulate therefore what should we do and
try to inspire this by our example that
seems to be the first and most important
question how are we to live and then
second how can I myself by trying to be
less certain of myself promote public
dialogue by opening my mind's the
possibility that I may be wrong if we
would each ask ourselves those two
questions how would I live and how would
I to stopped acting like those who
disagree with mirror evil if we could do
those two things I think we could
advance dialogue in the American and the
West general and perhaps in the world
enormously
hey